depuis 2008 l'opération art qui tente de
protéger le parc amazonien de cette
extraction illégale de l'or que
constitue leur paillage les hommes du
19è régiment de besançon faisait partie
de ces 500 soldats déployés chaque jour
sur le territoire guyanais un milieu
souvent hostiles ont découvert il ya
quelques mois les diables rouges de
colmar ce jour là il arrive sur un
chantier encore en activité
c'est dans ce bassin que les orpailleurs
vont puiser l'eau qu'ils utilisent après
avec un moto pompe qui les utilisent
après via le tuyau bleus et qui amène
sur une lance haute pression au fond des
caillons ça ça leur permet en fait de
casser la terre casser les bloque tout
ça se réduit en poudre et va en fait sur
une petite table en bois qu'on a déterré
tout à l'heure où il ya le fil à
l'intérieur
ce filtre ans une bête laver pour tenter
de récupérer les paillettes autour de
ces chantiers d'orpaillage la nature et
ravagé un désastre écologique due entre
autres à l'utilisation massive du
mercure qui détruit les rivières on a
une destruction des cours d'eau avec et
bien tous les sédiments qui vont qui
vont être relâchés dans les rivières des
rivières normalement voilà normalement
claire deviennent en fait des rivières
très très turbide et ça aussi ça sic si
les poissons et c'est un problème
environnemental est un problème de santé
publique avec des conséquences directes
sur la santé des populations locales qui
consomment les poissons des rivières
contaminé l'an passé l'opération harpie
a permis la destruction de 765 sites
clandestins d'orpaillage